الان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
فقد اشتدت حده المعارك الدائره في محيط
مدينه بخوت حيث تحاول القوات الروسيه
ووحدات فاجنر تطويق المدينه وقطع
الامدادات عن القوات الاوكرانيه وقالت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه سنه اكثر من خمسين هجوما صاروقيا
على البنيه التحتيه للمدينه في الجبهه
الشرقيه
وعلى المحور الشمالي لمدينه طباخ موت
شرقيه اوكرانيا نقل مراسل الجزيره عن
مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه
تحاول اختراق الدفاعات الاوكرانيه جنوب
قريه بارسكو فيفيكا واقرت المصادر بصعوبه
الوضع في هذا المحور مؤكده ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت قادره على صد الهجمات
وتكبيد القوات الروسيه خسائر كبيره على حد
وصفها وكانت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
اكدت في بيان صدها هجمات واسعه في اقليم
دومبس الشرقيه اوكرانيا واوضحت ان القوات
الروسيه تركز هجماتها على مدن اليمان
وبخبوتو